citizens of the reject Nation Greg is
being solo today because I asked around
to everyone who comes on this channel
and my biggest fears have been confirmed
I am the only one who has not seen the
much beloved Christopher Nolan classic
Memento I started at insomnia all the
way to Oppenheimer have not seen this
one though it's been one of those movies
that I've just been wanting to watch on
my own time I have no idea how well this
video will do but I figured if I was
planning already watching it just to
play some ketchup might as well point
the camera at me while I'm experiencing
this film and then ruin the experience
for all of you with that in mind a few
things I want to mention first off this
reaction upcoming is going to be edited
by the team over at prepper and I'm not
going to have any time to review their
edit so if it's crap blame them and if
it's great in your need of an editor I
highly recommend them they're generally
pretty freaking awesome people secondly
please go ahead leave a like that'd be
extremely appreciated if you can go
ahead and do that and as always
full-length Reaction watch along where
you sync up with your own copy of
memento available for our super sexy
rejects those are our patrons and thank
you again to all you citizens who have
converted yourselves to super sexy
citizens over there we have ourselves uh
many things that we cover exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included well with the limited
amount I know which is I believe this
movie's told backwards obviously Guy
Pierce is in it and it's a Noir film
those are my facts everything else it's
gonna be a big process of discovery
let's get into it
[Music]
Polaroid of a crime scene
Ah that's clever I just picked up on it
[Music]
I was late to pick it up on that
strange it actually goes backwards the
whole time
come on
oh damn you're in some hotel room you
just wake up and you're in in a motel
room there's the key you've been there
for a week three months cool this guy
he's here all right Lenny
it's a Leonard like I told you before
yeah
I must have forgot I love Joe pantaliana
so he killed him my car this is your car
oh you're in a playful mood it's not
good for you to make fun of someone's
handicap interesting all right well if
you win them
how did the window get to be that way so
where to Sherlock I got a lead on the
place that's just this building why do
you want to go there I don't remember
[Laughter]
it kind of feels like a Michael Mann
movie looks like somebody's home uh that
thing's been here for years we're
talking about these tracks for only a
few days old
take a look inside so as long as the
time span of his ability to remember
stuff Teddy
don't believe his lies he is the one
kill him I finally found him find
anything I kind of like his detached
Noir performance
yeah cool you freak beg my wife's
forgiveness before I blow your brains
out wife's forgiveness you don't know
who you are I'm Leonard Shelby I'm from
Sam come
you want to know any
oh that's a good mystery let's go down
you were made together
you'll know who you really are
no
tisk Sammy Jank has had the same problem
but he he really had no system you
really do need a system if if you're
gonna make it work like it's like the
early stages of his career development
of an obsessed pedantic
intelligent white man
and a loner too
all right okay so this is the scene
before the okay yeah I hope this does
not hurt my head I'm not sure I think I
may have asked you to hold my calls you
don't know it's my memory Amnesia no no
no I know who I am I know all about
myself I just since my injury I can't
make new memories damn what's the last
thing you remember
my wife
you know this guy yeah it's your friend
right what makes you think he's my
friend I just saw it together that's all
he's not my friend if he calls or if he
shows up here you give me a call in my
room okay there's a great Rhythm to the
dialogue you kind of learned to trust
your own handwriting where you put your
notes that also becomes really important
you need like a jacket that's got like
six pockets in it particular pockets for
particular things I wonder who he's
narrating to you have to be wary of
other people writing stuff for you that
is not going to make sense or I was
going to lead you astray I mean I I
don't know I guess people trying to take
advantage of somebody with this
condition he's shaving his leg it's nice
see Christopher Nolan movie where the
dialogue is so clear remember Sammy
jankus
what are the facts how often does he
discover this how is this crafted
together he left his at your table
thanks Lincoln Street oh yeah just go
straight out on 6th Street go east all
the way
down he shouldn't be behind a wheel it
seems so dangerous for him to be alone
discount in
Natalie
car
Teddy
John Edwards something or another
God told me his name was Teddy
I don't believe he's lies he killed my
wife that's not his real name
Mr Grandma John Gamble
okay okay so the clear-cut answer to the
mystery would have to be at the very
beginning of this story the one in color
right because the one in black and white
appears like it's moving in
chronological order
God I gotta get notes like this for an
upload schedule
that's why he was shaving his legs
I mean all signs seem to point to him
I like the soft-spoken coldness to guy
Pierce's performance
it's like a hollowness within his so
Hollow so
oh
does he not recall that's what exactly
happened to his wife what do we talk
about oh Sammy Jenkins Sammy's story
helps me understand my own situation I
have a more graceful solution to the
memory problem it's not that it's like
it's backwards when he looks down but in
a mirror
it's reflective of it all
at all
yeah she has also a lost someone she
will help you out of pity
solid assessment of an individual
ah the brilliant carrion Moss must be
tough living according to a couple
you mix your laundry list with your
grocery list and you'll end up eating
your underwear for breakfast I guess
that's why you have those freaky tattoos
oh man she embodies that great film Noir
performance here's a copy of his license
his registration photo and all are you
sure you want this have I told you what
this man did but even if you get revenge
you're not gonna remember it my wife
deserves Vengeance doesn't make any
difference whether I know about it Amen
brother
you can just feel the details
and you can feel these extreme moments
even if you don't want to you put these
together and you get the feel of a
person it's interesting seeing these
like crucifer Nolan motifs especially
the use of the flashbacks and the way he
shoots them shoots them like a dream I
added an address in here it's an
abandoned place outside of town
um a guy I knew used to do bigger deals
there it's isolated do I owe you I
wasn't helping you for money okay wait
is she framing Teddy you know what we
have in common
we are both survivors did she survive
something from Teddy he didn't even
inquire why she's all beat up I met
Sammy through work insurance I was an
investigator I'd investigate the claims
to see which ones were phony I had to
see through people's [__] it's
useful experience because now it's my
life okay good Exposition who are you on
the phone with we're gonna find out what
someone knew was just let him talk and
watch the eyes if someone scratches
their nose while they're talking experts
will tell you it means they're lying
Sammy was my first real challenge are we
gonna get to see Sammy
yo Lenny
I thought you split for good my name's
Teddy I guess I've told you about my
condition only every time I see you
the other day you mentioned that maybe
somebody was trying to set you up get
you to kill the wrong guy well I go on
fax not recommendations but thank you
you can't trust a man's life to you
little notes and pictures oh my god he
didn't kill your wife you really want to
get this guy don't you killed my wife I
took away my memory he destroyed my
ability to live fascinating I really
like he can't remember this guy but it
still feels like they got a history
together I'm checked in here but I think
I've misplaced my key how you doing
Leonard probably in the room right
I really love guy Pierce's performance
it's really like overly gentleman
kind of guy this is not my room no and
why is this my handwriting
this was your room but now you're in
304. I told my boss about the condition
and stuff and he said try and rent him
another room is he lying always get a
receipt I'll write that down
hey what time is it quarter one
your rooms he did it right down to
always get a receipt everyone's a
goddamn suspect doctors find some
possible damage to the hippocampus but
Sammy can't remember anything for more
than a couple of minutes his wife calls
the insurance company and I get sent in
looks like it's from completely other
era and this guy who couldn't even
follow the plot of Green Acres anymore
could do the most complicated things as
long as you learned before the accident
right but every time I see him I catch
this look slide look of recognition
familiarity yeah but he says he can't
remember me at all or is that in your
own head that you think that he
remembers this feels like a very
interactive film oh wait
oh where am I
oh somebody's bedroom
oh he's in carry on Moss's bedroom you
know it's great that you well it's true
helping me I'm helping you because you
help me how so next time you see me will
you remember me
what's happening
eyes open
I thought you split for good he was
right outside what the hell is going on
pick up any three objects
foreign
did give him a small shock they kept
repeating the test always with the same
objects electrified uh yeah Natalie
right who the [__] is Dodd
I guess I don't have to worry about him
anymore what the [__] have you got me
into oh my God you offered to help me
when you saw what he did to my face how
do I know he did that to your face
because I came straight to you after he
did it I showed you what he did and I
asked you to help me oh and I just take
your word yeah she's lying about some
[__] this
has nothing to do with you you helped me
out and I'm grateful
uh
uh doesn't have the photo I was
literally wondering if you had the photo
still I've lost somebody too his name
was
Jenny do kill him maybe I can help you
find him so she did frame him I don't
even know how long she's been gone it's
like I've woken up in bed and she's not
here because she's gone to the bathroom
or something dad this dude's gonna
forever be in a state of grief how
horrible how can I heal yeah exactly how
am I supposed to heal if I can't feel
Time Time
Heals all wounds and he doesn't get that
it's not a luxury but that's something
that's what he makes a dudes oh gotta
take that for granted don't I and time
is still an element of a Nolan film
like the way they draw these parallels
of a classic film Noir Dynamic with the
investigator detective the woman who
needs help but they're going to be like
doing inverses of the tropes I feel like
there's some big twists coming my way
and I'm trying to figure it out
she has also lost someone
she will help you out of pity that's a
oversimplification she identifies and
you guys have a bond there's almost an
anime-esque quality to guy Pierce's
performance there you get the impression
of like an apathetic type of delivery
but you could just sense you know sense
that it's all there so much pain we
turned on each claim on the grounds that
he wasn't covered from mental illness
his wife got stuck with the bills and I
got a big promotion that is horrible but
it works for me don't leave the way
Sammy couldn't have it and routine make
my life possible conditioning acting on
instinct
yeah
I mean whoa whoa whoa what's happening
awake
where am I what did we just see if is
that was that the flash of how he lost
his memory
just a minute
[Music]
I love how Heroes to always act like
he's composed and knows what he's
talking about
is that you don't know him is that John
G I don't think so you don't think so
you don't know you didn't write it down
I might have fallen asleep before I did
I just fell asleep so we take him down
to his car we come to get out of town or
we're gonna kill him we can't just walk
him out of here tied up and bleeding how
the [__] did you get him up here I don't
know
foreign
yes I do this is not my room
it must be his room great let's go no no
no no no no
let me clean him up and we March him out
of here with a gun in his back the gun
why would I have a gun
it must be his which one
what a great low budget psychological
Thriller this holds up so freaking well
so what do you do now
find out what the [__] that was all
about
this Teddy guy is too nonchalant about
what just went down hmm I don't feel
drunk
I would love to know what the writing
process of the script was they must have
written in a chronological order first
that had to do a complete rewrite place
it backwards like they must have had an
interesting whiteboard
this guy just like went to the bathroom
it wasn't like who's showering
is this guy hired to kill him God put
him on Teddy I'll just get rid of him
for Natalie Dodd
what nice penmanship he has this is a
message for Teddy I'm at the mount
Christ Inn on 5th Street room six I need
you to come over as soon as you get this
smart decision well what Mrs jancis
didn't understand was that you can't
bully someone into remembering the more
pressure under the harder it gets okay
so is the time of before a memory
restart process happened whatever it's
called restart process happens for him
again can be dependent on how stressful
the situation is for him
okay so what am I doing ah this just
happens in the middle of him ready I'm
chasing this guy
no he's chasing me
God he really needs a change of clothes
especially he's been running around in
that same shirt all day God white guys
Mount Christian on 5th Street
this guy has a very particular set of
skills
it's weird it's background is an
insurance agent but he really moves like
he's got some type of military or police
enforcement training of some sort you
know
the window is fine here we're gonna
finally see the origin of what happened
to his car window
[Music]
oh damn
okay so what am I doing there that
really sucks
ouch cut it out
it's just so interesting because he's
got the same almost the same exact style
of filmmaking he just does everything on
on a much bigger Grant a more Grand
scale now you know is it more refined it
knows how to work like IMAX cameras and
all these crazy big scale things there's
still so many similarities to his
filmmaking you know
you read it like a thousand times
I enjoy it I always thought the pleasure
of a book was in wanting to know what
happens next but don't be prick
just let me read
can't ever forget you what an ironic
line is a poetry to a lot of this now
the police report mentioned the drugs
found in the car outside of the house
the car was stolen but the prints were
all over the stuff they found in the car
just fit in with what they believed it
happened so they didn't chase any of it
up
so it's going to be that he killed his
own wife I don't know how I feel about
that if that's the twist I don't know
what's happening I mean it's late
everything okay
oh my God this is like the horror movie
version of 50 First Dates
because the police claim the guy was an
addict needing money to score which I
think is [__] because he's not gonna
go breaking into places while he's still
gonna snatch that big
Fair assessment
so he's a dealer
so fascinated by his wardrobe choice to
maintain wearing a suit specifically we
just go to bed you wait for me to fall
asleep go into the bathroom and you slam
the door
oh fascinating Alpha maintain some sense
of having a memory I mean look at Sammy
jancis his own wife couldn't deal with
it tell me if you really believe that
Sammy's faking his condition which you
honestly believe
why is it falling on him I believe that
Sammy should be physically capable of
making the memories
thank you I thought she just needed some
kind of answer I didn't think it was
important what the answer was
ah no what path did you send her down
man what path have you sent yourself
down that sounds like it was more
reflective for you you needed some kind
of answer
ready
I shot Leibowitz
this is the bar where she works wait a
boyfriend's a drug dealer she takes
Awards form arranges Meats he writes
messages on the back of these so her
boyfriend killed the goddammit she's
going to use you to protect herself
write this down do not trust her you
can't trust anyone and what exactly is
this guy's background
there you happy now I won't be happy
until you leave town oh that's what's
crossed off how did you get this suit
the car I have money from what my wife's
death so in your grief you wandered into
a Jaguar dealership
you don't even know who you are yes I do
oh my God that's what he said in his
death you wander around playing
detective you don't even know how long
ago it was wait how long ago was it do
not trust her
don't believe his lies
damn
no she shouldn't have given me that
responsibility
legal responsibility large Finance
never answer the phone
gnarly that is some trippy menacing
music man it just feels like a spiral
dog beat the [__] out of me why why
not Daddy you're safe it's okay
love how he never goes I don't remember
any of this
goes with the flow over time I'll go see
him yeah I'll give him some bruises of
his own and tell him to look for a guy
called Teddy
it's got dangerous that's just something
else okay I don't know man she seems
like such a manipulator
although I'm gonna look like a real
[__] if you actually did get messed
up
[Music]
you're a liar lady
I'm just so suspicious of everyone here
wait
was there a bruise on his knuckle did he
a car this nice you should lock so the
[__] are you
did he hit her and she was making up a
story what a tense Todd film
this mess is when you're at man who's
messing with your head calls himself
Dodd wants to know what happened to
Jimmy and his money he thinks I have it
he thinks I took it
did you no
he went to meet some guy named Teddy he
took a lot of money with me and he never
came back get rid of Dodge for me I'm
not going to kill someone for money what
then
kill for your wife wouldn't you that's
different not to me I wasn't married to
her hey don't talk about my wife oh man
this is bad I say whatever I want and
you won't remember I could call your
wife a [__] [__] we could just be
friends
great yes I can say whatever the [__] I
want and you won't have a [__] clue
oh my God
[__] you could write yourself a little
note about how much Natalie hates you
[__] guts and that I called your
wife hey don't say another word
yeah there it is you know one of the
causes of short-term memory loss is
venereal disease maybe you're of a
one too many disease
it turns you into
it
what are you doing oh and then she just
made up the whole story we'll still be
best friends
did punch her
and when she just waited outside or
something what did she do
stay focused good
no man your head's not a filing cabinet
that's what he was all he was doing was
looking for a goddamn pen
oh she just waited this [__] out this is
so stressful
write it down come on
what happened what does it look like he
beat the [__] out of me oh you cruel
evil woman if you have all of that
information
then why haven't the police found him
for you they don't think he exists I was
asleep
[Music]
damn oh damn
okay so he didn't kill his wife
there had to be a second man but you
can't trust your memory right
I don't know what to believe
he took the Dead Man's gun he replaced
it with a sap that he hit me with
he left my gun and he left to get away
car he gave the police a complete
package they didn't need to look for
anybody else
there is such a clever menace to this
make a step at home
at home one thing
that's why I took the photo
this film has such a great like menacing
dread to it I think this movie is better
than a lot of his other films
what
it's the last thing
that you do remember
my wife I remember my wife dying that's
not what he said
let me know get you another one
she poisoned him or something
I know you're a couple what do you want
if I did something wrong because of my
condition you don't believe someone with
this condition
nobody believed Sammy I didn't even
believe Sammy
he did not Sammy was faking I have no
short-term memory it's not amazing
you're the memory guy my boyfriend told
me about you Jimmy grants do you know
him in fact a cop came by earlier and
was looking for you
uh-huh are you teddy no my name's
Leonard what's happened to Jimmy
I don't know that either sorry you don't
remember where you've been or what
you've just done what did you just do I
found this in my pocket
pocket
did he steal that suit off someone yeah
this would have been just like a couple
years after the Matrix that's neat
oh that's why she here to continue nice
come on proceeds are going to charity
help me out
gross
ew
on the house thanks
oh that's mean like Sammy if I've done
something like Sammy I thought she was
just trying to catch me with guards so I
didn't tell her what I really thought
but I never said that he was faking just
that his condition was mental not
physical uh-huh it's time for my shot
you found a way to test him
oh no gave the shot again it's time for
my shot
hmm
man this little side story about Sammy
is some of the most heartbreaking [__]
I've seen in a while yeah she really
thought she'd call these Bluff
that won't hurt
oh no
she went into a coma never recovered
oh you gotta be kidding me he's been
home ever since he doesn't even know
that his wife is dead now I know you
fake it
you think he's supposed to recognize
somebody you just pretend to you Bluff
it to get a pat on the head from the
doctors so that's exactly what he does
every day
what are you still doing here Lenny well
I guess I just wanted to get something
down before it slipped my mind all right
then give me the keys I'm moving for you
it'll be all right for a minute wait out
there it's not safe for you to hang
around here anymore why not because the
cops looking for you he's been calling
you for days now telling you [__]
slipping envelopes under your door [__]
like that how do you know this he told
me he thinks it's funny is Teddy been
calling him up Jimmy's the drug dealer
the cop wants to know how his operations
run he's got some score in mind somehow
you're involved I'm a snitch
he's a cop from out of town the local
boys put us together uh okay I'll save
it real
wait what was the one before this now
I'm having a hard time remember the
placement I've seen so I was
why did he write that down I get the
impression Teddy's the only one who's
truthful with him and for some reason he
wrote that down because there's
something he doesn't want to believe
[Music]
hey Jimmy
he took Jimmy's Car
and Jimmy's clothes
did he kill Jimmy
but he's not gonna bring her along he'll
come by himself right
look at the drugs angle to be the best
way to get him you're in the lobby
I'll be right there so did he already
extract his revenge
is Teddy the cop I am not smarter than
this movie
[Music]
Teddy is the cop Lenny
officer Gamel
yeah
no never mind I was at officer or
Lieutenant Kim just Teddy this is the
directions where he's going
my numbers on the bottom if you need me
you're not coming no it wouldn't be
appropriate
I wouldn't be appropriate
make him beg
[Music]
this is
where the ending happened that's why
Teddy was upset to be returning back
here Teddy
you Jimmy Grant expecting any other
Jimmy's out here remember man do you
remember me
yeah I remember you why is he laughing
at him well
okay so this guy did not do it I knew he
couldn't trust that take it off your
pants too I'm confused why I don't want
to get blood on them
life back
dude
okay so this guy definitely didn't kill
his wife
[Music]
oh oh we're in color we've converged the
story lines
what have I done is that what he
there's a guy in here he's hurt bad we
gotta get him to a doctor
smart smart I've got this memory thing
do I know you no don't worry
still breathing well I don't know so he
actually is a cop this guy's dead ow
buddy that [__] killed you remember me
now huh
I'm the guy to help you find him get him
oh what's happening he knew me of course
he did your wife he picked up your brain
[__] he's not the guy his name is
James F grants John G check your tattoos
why is he framing him Jimmy's your guy I
just figured we'd make a few dollars on
the side how do you know me the discount
end he dealt out of there the guy at the
front desk let him know if anybody came
snooping around why would he be in the
house and kill his wife and stuff he
knew about Sammy why would I tell him
about
few little details you'd rather not
remember what what
your wife surviving the assault her not
believing your condition the torment and
and pain and anguish tearing her up
inside
the insulin
what it was your wife who had diabetes
ouch
oh I guess I can only make you remember
the things you want to be true like old
Jimmy down there he's not the right guy
he was to you
that's all that mattered why you're
never gonna know no you won't I will
somehow you won't remember that's done I
will know it'll be different well I
thought so too in fact I was sure of it
but you didn't
this isn't the first time
that's right
the real John G he's already got it
you'll find him over a year ago he's
already dead over a year ago we found
him you killed him but you didn't
remember
so I helped you start looking again this
is just the life he chooses to live a
couple of junkies too strung out to
realize your wife didn't live alone
but when you killed him I I was so
convinced that you'd remember but it
didn't stick how tragic I took that
picture just when you did it
I wanted to see that face again that's
sadistic how many John G's or James G's
I mean [__] Lenny I'm John G yep my
name's John Edward Gamel
cheer up there's plenty of John G's for
us to find unless you know Teddy's not a
good guy
come on what are you doing you know what
time it is it's beer o'clock I'm fine oh
this is when he he chooses to live he
don't believe his life it all makes
sense I'm not a killer
I'm just someone who wanted to make
things right
I just let myself forget what you've
told me
he's not a lot of time this is his life
how unsettling
forget what you've made me do
I think I just want another
brother John G to look for you're a John
G
oh man so you can be my Dungey
[Music]
hey that's not your car it is now
somebody will recognize it
somebody will I think I'd rather be
mistaken for a dead guy than a killer
will you help me find the keys
let me find my feet
wow
some Bleak ass [__] I have to believe
that my actions still have meaning
I have to believe that when my eyes are
closed the world's still here can't
trust your memory
[Music]
[Applause]
a tattoo father
now where was I
damn that holds up so well that was
amazing
that was really great oh my God
that
that really [__] in my head that was
great
all right let's talk about it man I
think I need uh
I need to digest that a little bit
that is real heady there's a lot on its
mind
and overall just a master class and
craftsmanship man it's so tense and
taught and the whole time I kept going
how did they construct this movie this
is one of those films that often you'll
get this with Christopher Nolan is you
want to know what the what is the
craftsmanship behind it how did they
develop the scenes here what did they do
in order to bring this to life to me
it's one of Nolan's best films honestly
I see why this movie was so talked about
and you could see like similarities of
this main character amongst many of the
other characters like well there's
always this uh inner conflict with them
and there's a constant nuance and
whatnot not always as as on display as
it is here to me this was so character
driven it was so character driven
dealing with a lot of different
questions and themes throughout
it didn't get too bogged down and any of
that and it also had a really unique
style and a really unique structure that
would suck you in even more and really
complemented the disorienting nature of
its storytelling
without just feeling like a gimmick I'll
get it out of the way I maybe felt like
five minutes of the film maybe five to
ten minutes of it was kind of dragging a
little bit I remember having that
thought
I cannot honestly tell you where that
thought happened specifically in the
movie though so that's really my one
little criticism is at one point I
thought it but then the movie
immediately had some switch happen where
I instantly got pulled back in uh yeah I
thought it was absolutely brilliant man
I think Nolan killed it here you know
for a guy who often makes films about uh
sounds weird to say manipulation this
movie deals so much obviously you know
with the I believe the word Memento has
something you know I'm just going to
look it up really fast because I know
Memento or like the physical items uh
like the objects and whatnot but where
does the word come from it means to
remember oh my God it's a double meaning
with your actual mementos that he's
using to dictate The Narrative of his
life and it also means to remember and
that you can't trust your memory
whoa so my mind is a little bit like a
little mind [__] right now I'm so used
to saying that with the Nolan film
because of it's like wow look at this
Grand level the master class filmmaking
or iMac stuff and and this to me just
blew me away because of stories it's
dealing so much with a nuanced
examination of
how memory can be manipulated of how our
memories can be unreliable I just love
how the themes are so like so strong and
and it factors in so much to who they
are as a character like everything was
just complimenting itself so well where
sometimes I feel like something like
this and sometimes with the Christopher
Nolan film honestly is he gets so bogged
down in the ideas and it's and dictating
those ideas to the audience
Without Really letting it register to
the characters but on the emotional
scale and even on the physical scale
because I love how the mementos
themselves are a form of manipulation as
well he's even manipulating the facts
he's manipulating the the things the
mementos is is literally manipulating
the the entire narrative
because this guy can't grieve and he's
got such a conflict about his own
identity in this world and this is the
thing they can give him his sense of
self this is the thing that he give him
uh an actual purpose in life
it's really thought provoking and it it
gets you to kind of think about your own
self-perception it makes you also like
my mind's going to be zigzagging a lot
here because we're dealing with so much
about memory it does make you start to
question your own memory because they're
talking about how it could factor into
your own biases and whatnot and the idea
that he is trying to illustrate to Teddy
in that one scene in a diner about like
he's relying on cold hard facts you
can't even rely on that and this is
supposed to be the physical
representation of the memory because
he's not going to rely he can't rely on
his actual own memory with the style and
the way this was done sometimes you find
yourself trying like I like how the the
scenes whenever they would go backwards
they would still end like the the not
the non-linear ones told in Reverse they
would still end on the scene that came
prior because sometimes I would be
having to jog my own memory of wait so
it kind of messes with the audience in
its own way too from a structural and
editing standpoint of wait a minute what
what was the prior scene I need to try
to remember what the prior scene is as
the other multi-layer of having you
trying to pick up on all these Clues and
try to remember everything that's being
said because you could tell that this
movie is leading to some big reveal and
you want to kind of figure it out and
you're also trying to try to figure it
out with Leonard along the way as well
you're also trying to remember stuff is
it's this fascinating game about memory
and I'm more used to knowing messing
with time and while this movie obviously
deals so much with time and there's this
element of time the conversation as well
about how time is the gift that we get
in times of grief and he is not allotted
that but at the same time a lot seems to
be compounded with because of the
fragility of the situation that he's in
and the unreliability of his own memory
that a lot of it also seems to be
compacted with because he he can't
grieve that he so much of this is just
in denial as well sometimes when Teddy
is talking to him and they're doing the
fly in the finale or the beginning when
Teddy's talking to him and giving him uh
you know like the the actual truth bombs
of the situation he gets these like
little flashes you know one can argue
that maybe it's just Teddy messing with
his perception his whole perspective of
things it's so much of the perspective
of stuff they come in these like I like
the way that Nolan handles those
flashbacks it's kind of like the way he
he can do it on time where it's just
these little quick inserts it's kind of
the way like a lot of us remembers like
these brief little moments in time the
disorienting nature of his own memories
makes you then as the viewers suddenly
go
wait a minute
is this just his imagination
can he trust his memory that what Teddy
is saying that he's actually getting a
flash of an actual memory or is it
messing with his own memory in that
moment so you don't even really know
what the entire truth is I mean
it seems like that would be the truth
though I feel like what we got at the
end was the actual truth Leonard already
did find the guy and that Teddy is a
corrupt cop who has been
turning him into a vigilante of source
for his own game to make money that
would explain then because they don't
make it explicitly clear
that the Dobbs guy was going after
Carrie Anne Moss's character Natalie
because he used to work he thought Jimmy
ran off with the money right did I piece
that together I think I pieced that
together and like the performances too
my God we're getting so caught up in and
so caught up in like trying to piece
together my own thoughts here because
this movie did a number on me I love guy
Pierce's performance here you know the
at times where he would seem
it's like he always had to set that
determination but there was
the way he would play masking the
confusion that he would have at the
beginning of all those scenes and still
having this vulnerability
allows you to empathize for the sky
who you know through a lot of the story
you're going
you know you can't trust any of these
people but then you start to question
can I even trust my main character right
now even by the very end as dark of an
ending as it is you still actually feel
really sorry for the guy but I thought
he brought a wide array of emotions to
Performance felt very human and yet
struck just the right kind of tone to
make this it's like an unforgettable
performance to me because this is the
kind of performance that needs to hit
this certain kind of pitch in order for
like because the plot's a little
ridiculous like when you really break it
down it's like it's a little ridiculous
right they make it very believable but
it's it's a little far-fetched because
this dude with this it's not I forget
what the condition is called but this
dude with the con with the memory
condition
doing all this it's a little far-fetched
I don't know maybe maybe people can
actually pull it off but to me it's it's
a little suspended disbelief right
but the way he captures the grief the
way he captures the obsession the way he
captures the the anger this entire
internal struggle there's a lot of great
subtleties he's also really charming and
funny and I think he really does bring a
compelling insight into this character's
fragmented reality essentially
consistent throughout and he really
carries his film so strong thought it
was an unforgettable performance and he
really carried this movie you know
sometimes I feel like Nolan lead
characters can be just there to serve it
I mean really I'm just kind of thinking
of like
the most part there's always a death
provided a depth provided Hey Leonardo
DiCaprio also had a whole dead wife
thing in uh Inception
Booyah and he's also a really smart
detective like character there are these
kind of like know the knee tropes and
then carrian Moss of course man
um
master manipulator her her incredible
ability to oscillate between being
vulnerable and being manipulative
this kind of character could have felt
one-dimensional but she really wasn't
she really brought a lot of depth to the
role and I thought the ambiguity that
you brought where you were just like
what is This Woman's true intentions so
strong
it keeps the audience really really
engaged and you're and you're also like
what exactly is a role in Leonard's life
what's going on here it was a great
performance and I like the back and
forth that her and Guy Pierce had but
she still had a wide spectrum of
emotions as well you know like her
compassion and tenderness would seem
believable but then her anger and
ruthlessness for her own Revenge was uh
so repulsive man she really nailed it
down but she had some great subtlety as
well everyone had some great subtlety
and freaking Joey pants my man uh talk
about ambiguity another guy who you know
trying to serve as like Leonard's guide
but you know he's doing that because
he's really manipulating him and wants
to is using him but he would fluctuate
so much between ah no you killed the
wrong guy Leonard uh I think I think
maybe Teddy's the good guy the whole
time and the if the movie does such a
good job of making you fluctuate between
is he good is he bad I can't tell but
you really do get a sense that even
though Joey pants likes to use him the
teddy likes to use him that Teddy
actually does kind of like the guy that
Teddy does feel sorry for him and he
does that actually like him despite the
fact that he's a a shitty cop who in the
end seems like he actually deserved to
die but they also do have a a great
chemistry that has a lot of tension to
it as well with this great mix of like
yeah it was like a great mix where it
would be like frustration distrust
cynicism with like moments that felt
welcoming and and warm at the same time
uh
yeah it was the the performances all
around were very powerful as well
a lot of great moral ambiguity to the
entire thing and
uh man I'm I'm a little bit blown away
by this and this is one of those things
like when we talked about Oppenheimer
that was something where had some a
little bit of time to think about it
like a few minutes and then going right
into it and here you know there's
I'm a little bit more mind blown by this
because this is such an original idea
that has a lot of great things that a
hearken back to you know film Noir
tropes uh but there's a lot on its mind
you know that deals with vengeance
Obsession Justice the
um uh Truth Versus
reality uh the subjective side of of
reality too
and
just a entertaining ass movie at the
same time underneath this entire package
of like brilliant Cinema it's just a
really entertaining film I I thought it
was exciting and it it had me suckered
in from beginning to end and there was
this one part of me that was like oh
this is like really early Nolan days I
wonder if it's gonna be kind of boring I
had a big concern that that this movie
was over hyped for me
and
that's partly why I put it off because
you know I came in at an insomnia which
I like Pacino and uh Robin Williams and
and after that I was I think about after
that it was Batman Begins and then all
the other films are now like Prestige
and whatnot so I I thought I'm so used
to like this really exciting Nolan this
is like his low budget Nolan this is
gonna be boring it's gonna be a boring
film and it wasn't I thought I genuinely
thought it was one of his best because
it deals so much with self-perception
it's on personal identity
sense of self
um your own personal belief system
Karma and
and uh trauma I loved it I I loved it I
really loved that movie I'm glad I
watched it man that was a really
exciting film
with a great grip on on uh
I wonder if like Nolan today would would
make a movie like this because I know
he's like the big Cinema guy now but man
I love this just zeroed in low budget
like that's a lot with a little because
it doesn't feel expensive nor does it
feel cheap if that makes sense uh you
know and sometimes like they told the
right story and it seemed like they they
got all the right necessary amounts of
money some stuff is a little
questionable of course of how come cops
never chasing down this guy where you
know he's driving around with a very
identifiable car there's gunshots going
off maybe that's something to do with
the Crime Boss stuff or the I mean like
Jimmy was a crime boss right he's worked
for someone so maybe they wouldn't call
the cops because of it
then again Teddy was on the case so
maybe he was manipulating stuff there's
a lot of things that where you can kind
of fill in and go maybe this is why this
happened maybe this is why this didn't
happen to me this is why this didn't
happen
um but overall yeah I thought it was an
amazing film and
again sorry for just like trailing left
and right there was just so much
processing of Amazement from being from
having such a marvelous splendiferous
experience with this movie that I was
processing simultaneously we're trying
to talk about it I should have made
notes that would have really helped me
out uh but right now yeah
um
thank you for being here
and I will talk with you all soon
[Music]